Michael Keaton's Batman officially
returns in the flash we've known about
it for a while but actually getting to
see him on screen again has set the
internet wild with excitement here's
what everybody online had to say the
highly anticipated Super Bowl 57 trailer
for The Flash got fans buzzing before
the big game on Sunday the Blockbuster
tees presented the anxious DC fandom
with several jaw-dropping Revelations
and eye-opening little details as a
result the fans have a fair share of
things to be excited about when the film
drops in June during the trailer not one
but two Barry Allen's unite to try and
undo the Damage Done when the flash
breaks the speed force causing an
existential meltdown across timelines
newcomer Supergirl and a returning
General Zod have their moments but it's
Michael Keaton's return as Batman that
really put this trailer over the top
keys and the prizes adore roles of
billionaire Bruce Wayne and The Dark
Knight detective he originally portrayed
in Tim Burton's 1989 Batman yeah
[Music]
I'm Batman for kids and it's been nearly
35 years since he first suited up to
fight crime in Gotham City but returning
to the role and putting the bad suit
back on after all these years was easier
than fans might think in an interview
with Jake's takes Keaton said it was
shockingly normal weird and like I went
oh oh yeah that's right the return of
Keaton's Batman is arguably the high
water mark for the flash despite all of
its core characters even the film's
titular star and it seems the fans will
accept almost anything The Flash has to
offer thanks to Keaton's involvement in
the project one YouTuber posted in the
comments of the new trailer seeing
Michael Keaton as a dark knight again
after 34 years just brought the tear to
my eye this movie is going to be epic
Keaton's crime fighting Bruce Wayne last
appeared in 1992's Batman Returns which
was also helmed by Tim Burton and
there's no denying that the DC fandom is
happy to have him back another commenter
wrote not gonna lie I got teary-eyed
seeing Michael Keaton back as Batman
Keaton's version of The Dark Knight
seems like he's going to be a major
player in the flash judging from the
Super Bowl trailer and many of the fans
are incredibly grateful another YouTuber
wrote words can't express how much it
means to me to see Michael Keaton back
as Batman thank you most of the chatter
following the Flash Super Bowl drop
seems to be focused on the bat so it
shouldn't come as a surprise that fans
are willing to put up with multiple Ezra
Miller's just to see Keaton Don the cowl
again
my face she stole my face one user on
Twitter posted I'm up for DC
disappointing me again just to watch
Michael Keaton play Batman one more time
and Miller may be playing the titular
role but some fans will buy tickets for
the sole purpose of witnessing Keaton
clad in the bat suit again composer
Brian Ralston tweeted I hope Warner
Brothers Pictures properly interprets
that people are going to see this film
and they will be successful because of
Michael Keaton returning to be Batman in
it and not because of Ezra Miller just
saying for other fans Miller's
off-screen issues might have kept them
from watching The Flash altogether had
it not been for the inclusion of
Keaton's Batman one Twitter user said I
was mad when they didn't pull this movie
because of all the actor was doing but I
really want to see this especially
Michael Keaton he's the best hopefully
the hype surrounding Keaton's return and
the film will pay off come June
foreign